But I'll give you one quick example,
I say,
and it's fairly standard because I
believe it strongly,
the American dream is dead,
but I'm going to make it bigger and
stronger and better.
I think it's safe to say that social
tensions within Western society have
risen dramatically since the century.
How do you elicit concepts like
multiculturalism and the American dream
has come under increasing amounts of
scrutiny from all sides of the political
spectrum and the Mitsui growing
suspicion,
discontent over matters like government,
race,
ethnicity,
gender,
and religion.
There's the realization that we've
become so self aware that we've become
too scared to even have an honest debate
about these very subjects that have
since become taboo.
And in order to evaluate our relations,
you concept like the American dream,
we might just have to look in one of the
most unexpected of places,
la,
la.
Now you don't have to be an analytical
genius to understand.
And Harold and Kumar,
it's about far more than the struggle to
young potheads the perfect fast food
this night,
the American dream.
So let's talk about the American dream
for a second,
generally defined as the ideals of
freedom and equality for all American
citizens,
but maybe most importantly,
it's the guarantee that within this
landscape,
every individual has the opportunity to
achieve success in whatever it is they
might pursue.
On a surface level,
it seems that the movie aligns itself,
Isi Culture,
as the story's about two members of
minority groups trying to seeing the
fruits of that concept that should be
readily available to every American by
default.
However,
we only have to examine the two main
protagonists who discovered it.
This observation is in fact false.
Both Harold and Kumar seemed to embody
the group in the stereotypical Asian
American and Indian American.
Harold is shown to be hardworking,
anxiety,
non provoking,
and shy.
Waterfalls and studer group identity of
the smart,
well educated Indian American.
With the talent for the medical
professions,
it quickly becomes clear ever.
There's more to the east characters and
just their stereotypes.
I can't party tonight.
Okay,
I going to stay late at the office.
Dude.
Fuck that shit.
We had friends I know,
but I got a lot of work to do.
When is getting high ever prevented you
from doing your work
held in whom are actually shown Zvi
route or a stereotypical as they smoke
weed,
pursue sexual desires and make quads I
racist jokes through their friends.
You you'd use think about tits homes is
there also seemed to be highly conscious
of their struggle with their proposed
group identity.
Kumar has no interest in as far as the
man that he becomes.
A dark room is dirty and filled to the
brim with posters or black rep artists
and attempt to appropriate black culture
in favor of his own federal,
on other hand,
still actively Ozon to a large part of
his group and you showed you more
hesitant and Kumar to break away from
his character traits cleared at both
harold and Kumar have a desire to be
someone else to be their own versus at
the beginning of the movie,
both characters are essentially stuck in
their struggle to find your own
identities in relation to their proposed
group.
They're both stereotypical as well as a
stereotypical.
No,
no,
no.
I don't like breaking the law,
makes very clear that is not doing a way
with ethical stereotypes what is ratter
and quite literally poking holes in
them,
in fact,
poking holes into stereotypes but not
doing away with them completely becomes
one of the main themes of the movie.
They have a Gelato,
evangelicals,
this multiethnic comedy,
because a story allows the main
characters to interact with people from
a variety of ethnic groups.
Instead of focusing on a group,
the main characters themselves during
these interactions,
Harold and discovered that they choose
are guilty of stereotyping potters
because every person they need one of
their quote unquote reality bubbles pop.
First off,
Harold was hesitant to spend time with
the East Asian Club at Stanford as it
seemed to embody to fool stereotypical
group identity of Asian Americans,
humanity,
just to avoid having to go to party only
to find out that there are parties are
absolutely crazy.
Stick it hit you,
Tamara meats too.
Posh British girls who want to meet up
for a night of fun and it turned to
prevent is harold and Kumar.
Ended up in the girl's bathroom and find
out just how class you'd these ladies
are
later on if it was shown to be an overly
stereotypical Jesus loving redneck Kumar
clearly uncomfortable around him and so
he tells them that are allowed to have
sex with his wife.
Lastly,
when Harold ends up in police custody
after having punched a police officer,
he needs a black American man,
but this time is different.
Demand doesn't look like the
stereotypical like plug.
It seems to be quite the opposite.
As he's reading a compilation of essays
called civil disobedience.
He explained to commodity has been
arrested unfairly.
Then ads that he doesn't get too worked
up about it
in the end,
universe tends done as it should
have a really large penis that keeps me
happy.
Not the first line is arguably the most
important line of the entire movie,
and I'll get back to that in a second,
but the second line obviously reinforces
a stereotype of black men and their son.
David Jolanta explains this recurring
theme and at the movie Los,
every guy to identify themselves in
relation to the stereotypes about your
ethical group is not to say that all the
minority characters in our Kumar,
Sharon's been victims of his legacy.
On the contrary,
even the one person who can legitimately
be seen as a victim refuses to see
himself as such.
In.
Besides that,
most of the auto minority characters
don't seem to take their ethnical
identities very seriously and even
actively engaged in self ridiculed.
You know the Holocaust?
Yeah,
picture the exact opposite of that.
There still definitely an argument to be
made how Harold and Kumar are being held
back by external forces who seem to be
predominantly white.
It's no coincidence that the castle to
the American dream is called white
guests,
but as we've seen how leukemia is not
about complete generalizations and
victimization,
and this seems to be the last bubble to
pop.
We're two friends,
extreme sports bullies and racist cops
are ultimately arrested by police
officers.
Even Neil Patrick Harris redeems himself
by being for Hilton Kumar's food as
they're stealing their car.
So it seems to intellectual black guy
was right,
the universe,
Dustin,
to shoot in the end,
how whom I reached their American dream,
harold finally rebels against his own
conformity with social conditioning as
he stands up to his coworkers and
ultimately gets the girl.
Kumar,
on the other hand,
is now more accepted of his ability to
potentially become a great surgeon and
decides that it's time to let go of
resisting the Spartan you make do with
what you have.
Seems to be the central message here.
Yes,
there will always be people who are
living a little easier.
Yes,
there were always real assholes and
bigots.
There will always be individuals trying
to hold you back,
but it's up to you whether you let that
affect you in whether you can allow
yourself to not take everything so
seriously.
It's our own convictions and our
perception of the world that can hold us
back the most.
That's why Harold and Kumar is about the
American dream.
It's about reevaluating yourself within
the spectrum of group identity and
individuality to them,
proactively work your way towards that
dream to let go of victim and to find
the courage to teach or lead.
Oh,
great.
Hey guys,
thanks for watching.
If you liked this video and don't mind
telling your friends about it,
please do not hesitate to share it and
give your thoughts on it in the comment
section below.
Next video will be our 24 and the Bourne
ultimatum analysis.
We had some technical issues with that
one,
but it will come out somewhere in the
beginning of next week.
See you guys.
Then.